ROLL [inaudible]
ALLEN [inaudible]
ARCHULETA [inaudible]
ATKINS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
BELL [inaudible]
GORGEOUS [inaudible]
BRADFORD [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
DORADO [inaudible]
GALGIANI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
HERTZBERG [inaudible]
HUESO --
TADO [inaudible]
JACKSON [inaudible]
JONES [inaudible]
LEYVA [inaudible]
MCGUIRE [inaudible]
MITCHELL [inaudible]
MORE LOCK [inaudible]
MORRELL [inaudible]
NIELSEN [inaudible]
PAN [inaudible]
PORTANTINO [inaudible]
ROTH [inaudible]
RUBIO [inaudible]
STERN [inaudible]
STONE [inaudible]
NUMBER [inaudible]
WHY CASKEY [inaudible]
WIENER [inaudible]
WILK.
COLLEAGUES A QUORUM IS PRESENT
WITH THE MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BE ON THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE.
WE WILL BE LEAD IN PRAYER THIS
AFTERNOON BUYER CHAPLAIN SISTER
MACHEL GORMAN AFTER WHICH PLEASE
REMAIN STANDING WE WILL BE LED
IN THE PLEDGE OF ALLEGIANCE TO
OUR FLAG.
BY SENATOR PORTANTINO.
LET US REMEMBER THIS WEARING
GOD'S HOLY PRESENCE.
GRACIOUS AND MERCIFUL GOD.
WE PRAY FOR THE POWER TO BE
GENTLE.
THE STRENGTH TO BE FORGIVING.
THE PATIENTS TO BE UNDERSTANDING.
AND THE INSURANCE TO ACCEPT THE
CONSEQUENCES OF HOLDING ON TO
WHAT WE TRUST TO BE RIGHTS.
MAY WE KNOW THE POWER OF GOODS
AND THE POWER OF LOVE. TO CREATE
A NEW WORLDS.
WHERE FEAR AND SELFISHNESS NO
LONGER LEAD PEOPLE TO COMMIT
INJUSTICE OR BRING SUFFERING TO
OTHERS?
WE PRAY FOR VISION TO SING AND
FAITH TO BELIEVE.
IN A WORLD EMANCIPATED FROM
VIOLENCE.
HELP US TO DIVERSE OUR ENERGY.
TO THE TASK OF MAKING PEACE.
AND INSPIRING ALL TO CONTRIBUTE
THEIR GIFTS. FOR THE
PRESERVATION OF HUMANITY.
A MAN.
I HAVE.
IS [inaudible]
AND AND WHAT.
THERE IS A LITTLE RED.
YEAH CRAWL.
GOOD AFTERNOON COLLEAGUES AND
GOOD AFTERNOON TO THE YOUNG
FOLKS IN THE GALLERY.
WELCOME TO THE STATE CAPITOL.
AND ALSO A WELCOME TO THE STATE
CAPITOL BY OUR FORMER COLLEAGUES
COLLEAGUES IF WE COULD GIVE A
VERY NICE WARM WELCOME. TO THE
SENATORS ROD RIGHT AND KEVIN
MARI WHO HAVE JOINED US HERE ON
THE FLOOR TODAY WELCOME BACK.
AND OF COURSE ALSO A FOREIGN
WELCOME TO OUR FRIEND AND
COLLEAGUE FRIEND PAVLEY FORMER
SENATOR BRADLEY IS WITH US.
AS WELL [inaudible] ONE I
MENTIONED [inaudible]
WELCOME BACK.
COLLEAGUES WE WILL NOW PROCEED
TO PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
STARTING WITH OUR PRO TâM.
SENATOR ATKINS THE FLOOR IS
YOURS.
CHIEF OF HIS WORK AND HEARING
THAT PRODUCE THE DIGNITY.
YUBA [inaudible]
THANK YOU WHICH YOU'RE ALL
WELCOME.
TO COLLEAGUES IF YOU COULD
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION AS
SENATOR.
ATKINS WILL BE PRESENTING OUR
DISTINGUISHED GUEST.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH IT IS AN EXCITING DAY ON
THE FLOOR WE ARE WELCOMING
LONGTIME FRIENDS AND NEW FRIENDS
TO THE CHAMBER SO I I CERTAINLY
UNDERSTAND THE EXCITEMENT --
BUT I AM VERY EXCITED TO
INTRODUCE AND WELCOME ANOTHER
PERSON HERE TODAY WE'RE FLYING
THE FLAG OF CUBA THIS AFTERNOON.
IN HONOR OF A VERY DISTINGUISHED
GUESTS THAT WE HAVE RIGHT HERE
BESIDE ME.
IT GIVES ME GREAT PLEASURE TO
INTRODUCE FRANK AT THE FIRST
SECRETARY OF THE EMBASSY OF THE
REPUBLIC OF CUBA IN WASHINGTON
DC.
MR FREGAT HAS SERVED IN THIS
POSITION SINCE THE RE
ESTABLISHMENT OF DIPLOMATIC
RELATIONS BETWEEN THE UNITED
STATES AND CUBA.
IN JULY OF TWENTY FIFTEEN MANY
OF US --
FEEL VERY GOOD ABOUT THOSE
RELATIONSHIPS A NUMBER OF US
HAVE BEEN TO CUBA QUITE A FEW
TIMES I'VE HAD THE OPPORTUNITY.
TO GO ON TWO OCCASIONS I'D SEE A
NUMBER OF MY COLLEAGUES HERE WHO
HAVE ALSO MADE THAT TRIP.
SO WE'RE ESPECIALLY PLEASED TO
BE ABLE TO HAVE YOU HERE TODAY.
PREVIOUSLY --
MISTER FREY GET SERVED HIS
COUNTRY IN THE NORTH AMERICAN
AND U. S. DIVISIONS OF THE
MINISTRY OF FOREIGN AFFAIRS AT
THE CUBAN EMBASSY IN CANADA ONE
OF OUR OTHER --
PARTNERS TO THE NORTH AND IS A
MEMBER OF THE PROVINCIAL
PARLIAMENT FOR HAVANA.
MR FRAGEN HAS TRAVELED FAR AND
WIDE ACROSS THE UNITED STATES
VISITING UNIVERSITIES NON
PROFITS OFFICIALS AT ALL LEVELS
OF GOVERNMENT. TO HELP BUILD
STRONGER RELATIONS WITH CUBA
MANY OF YOU WILL REMEMBER HS
MOST RECENT VISIT TO THIS
CHAMBER JUST IN. TWENTY SIXTEEN
TWENTY NINETEEN MARKS A YEAR A
GREAT CHANGE FOR THE ISLAND
NATION OF CUBA.
PRESIDENT MIGUEL DE IS CAN NOW
HAS PUT FORWARD A REWRITE OF THE
CUBAN CONSTITUTION AS MANY OF
YOU WERE PAYING ATTENTION TO THE
NEWS YESTERDAY.
YOU SAW --
THAT VOTE --
IT HASN'T BEEN REVISITED AND
SINCE NINETEEN SEVENTY SIX THE
REFERENDUM ON THE NEW
CONSTITUTION WAS HELD YESTERDAY
FEBRUARY TWENTY FOURTH HE
RETURNS TO CALIFORNIA.
OUR CAPITAL TO SHARE INFORMATION
ABOUT THE NEW CONSTITUTION AND
THE FIVE HUNDREDTH ANNIVERSARY
CELEBRATION.
OF THE CITY OF HAVANA LATER THIS
YEAR.
I IT IS A REAL WONDERFUL --
TIME TO WELCOME YOU AND ME PRIOR
TO COMING IN WE HAD A CHANCE TO
VISIT.
THAT MORE THAN HALF MADAM
PRESIDENT YOU WILL BE
PARTICULARLY PLEASED TO HEAR
MORE THAN HALF OF THE PARLIAMENT
IS WOMEN ARE WOMEN.
AND SO I TOLD HIM WE HAVE A WAYS
TO GO.
WE ONLY HOPE TO EMULATE --
THE WORK THAT YOU HAVE DONE IN
CUBA SO PLEASE JOIN ME IN
WELCOMING OUR FRIEND MR FOR I GO
BACK.
TO OUR CHAMBER.
OF A WARM WELCOME. TO OUR
DISTINGUISHED GUEST.
IT ALSO PRODUCES SOME OF THE
GREAT BASEBALL PLAYERS WHO PLAY.
IN OUR LEAGUE HERE IN THE UNITED
STATES
.
THANK YOU FOR JOINING US TODAY.
NEXT TO A
A SENATOR SKINNER
WOULD YOU LIKE TO MAKE AN
INTRODUCTION. TO OUR INTRODUCING
OUR EXUBERANT YOUNG FOLKS UP IN
THE GALLERY CAUGHT COLLEAGUES IF
YOU COULD GIVE.
YOUR ATTENTION TO SENATOR
SKINNER PLEASE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH WANNA GIVE A
WARM SENATE WELCOME TO SECOND
AND THIRD GRADERS THAT ARE HERE
JOINING US FROM VINCENT ACADEMY
IN WEST OAKLAND.
AND THEY'RE HERE AS PART OF
THEIR WORK ON THEIR BUILDING THE
DREAM BLACK HISTORY PERFORMANCE
SO THEY'RE LEARNING ABOUT
GOVERNMENT.
HELLO WELCOME TO GET OUR CHAMBER.
THE ROCKETS FOLKS FROM.
OAKLAND [inaudible]
THE SENATOR MITCHELL.
DO YOU HAVE FOR A ALL RIGHT.
A PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR MITCHELL AND SENATOR
HERTZBERG THANK YOU FOR THE
DEATHS COLLEAGUES IF YOU WOULD.
PLEASE GIVE YOUR ATTENTION TO
SENATOR MITCHELL SENATOR
MITCHELL THE FLOOR IS YOURS
THANK YOU VERY MUCH MADAM
PRESIDENT HAPPY MONDAY
COLLEAGUES ARE LAST MONDAY OF
BLACK HISTORY MONTH.
I RISE TODAY TO COMMEMORATE THE
CONTRIBUTIONS OF A VERY HARD
WORKING IMPORTANT NONPROFIT
ORGANIZATION IN MY DISTRICT A
NEW WAY OF LIFE IN THEIR RE
ENTRY LEGAL CLINIC.
MORE THAN SEVEN MILLION
CALIFORNIANS OR ONE IN THREE
ADULTS IN OUR STATE HAVE AN
ARREST OR CONVICTION RECORD.
THESE ARREST AND CONVICTION
RECORDS OFTEN NEGATIVELY AFFECT
THE LIVES OF FORMALLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUALS.
ESPECIALLY IN TERMS OF
EMPLOYMENT HOUSING OPPORTUNITIES
IN EDUCATION.
I HAD A CONVERSATION A RECENTLY
WITH THE YOUNG MAN WHO IS AN
ACTIVE THIS ALL A FORMERLY
INCARCERATED INDIVIDUAL WHO'S
AND ACTIVISTS WHO.
IS BEAUTIFULLY GAINFULLY
EMPLOYED IS ABLE TO BUY A HOME
BUT BECAUSE OF HIS PREVIOUS
CONVICTION HE CAN'T BE AN ACTIVE
MEMBER OF HIS HOME OWNERS
ASSOCIATION.
YOU CAN BUY THE HOUSE BUT YOU
CAN'T BE ON I'LL SEE ACTION
THINGS FOR US TO THINK ABOUT
COLLEAGUES AS WE WORK HARD TO
REDUCE RECIDIVISM AND SUPPORT RE
ENTRY SERVICES.
AGAIN IN MANY INSTANCES THE
SOCIAL LEGAL BARRIERS TO
REENTERING SOCIETY --
IMPACT CALIFORNIA PRO ROWLEY'S
AND THERE IS A TIM TO REENTER.
THE IN THE NEED FOR RE ENTRY
RELIEF IN LA A NEW WAY OF LIFE
FOR YOU TO PROJECT AND THE
CRITICAL RACE STUDIES PROGRAM AT
UCLA SCHOOL OF LAW.
JOINTLY ESTABLISH THE PRO BONO
LEGAL CLINIC THE HELP CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS OVERCOME RE ENTRY
BARRIERS.
SINCE THE RE ENTRY CLINIC LEGAL
CLINIC HAS BECOME SINCE THE IN
THE CLINIC HAS BECOME THE
LARGEST PRO BONO LEGAL CLINIC OF
IT'S KIND IN SOUTHERN CALIFORNIA.
AND ONE OF THE FOREMOST EXPERTS
IN LEGAL ISSUES RELATED TO
COLLATERAL CONSEQUENCES OF MASS
INCARCERATION IN OUR STATE. TO
DATE THE RE ENTRY LEGAL CLINIC
HAS FILED OVER EIGHT THOUSAND
THREE HUNDRED PETITIONS FOR POST
CONVICTION RELIEF.
REMEMBER COLLEAGUES SEVERAL ARE
BALLOT INITIATIVES HAVE CREATED
THE OPPORTUNITY FOR PEOPLE TO
HAVE THESE --
THEIR RECORDS EXPUNGED BUT THERE
IS A LEGAL PROCESS THAT YOU HAVE
TO GO THROUGH TO MANAGE THAT
PROCESS AND THIS LITTLE LEGAL
CLINIC IS HELPING CALIFORNIA
RESIDENTS GET IT DONE.
WHEN INDIVIDUALS ORGANIZATIONS
SEE IN NEED IN THEIR COMMUNITIES
AND TACKLE TOUGH CHALLENGES TO
MEET THAT NEED?
THESE.
ORGANIZATIONS COMPLEMENT THE
WORK WE DO HERE AS POLICY MAKERS
TO MAKE CALIFORNIA AND EQUITABLE
AND THRIVING STATE.
AGAIN ON BEHALF OF THE RESIDENTS
IN MY DISTRICT I'M HONOR TO
RECOGNIZE AND CONGRATULATE A NEW
WAY OF LIFE RE ENTRY LEGAL
CLINIC FOR TEN YEARS OF
OUTSTANDING PUBLIC SERVICE.
COLLEAGUES SO STORY IN OUR
NATION TO THE WORLD OF THIS
OUTSTANDING GROUP
.
COLLEAGUES ARE THERE ANY OTHER
PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR.
SEEING NONE WE WILL MOVE ON TO
MESSAGES FROM THE GOVERNOR WILL
BE DEEMED READ MESSAGES FROM THE
ASSEMBLY WILL BE DEEMED READ
REPORTS OF COMMITTEES WILL BE
DEEMED READ AND AMENDMENTS
ADOPTED.
UNDER MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES ARE THERE ANY MOTIONS
RESOLUTIONS OR NOTICES.
SAYING NON.
WE WILL DO THE INTRODUCTION ON
THE FIRST READING OF BILLS
MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ.
SENATE BILL FIVE FORTY ONE FIVE
FORTY TWO BY 435-404-5405 BY
FORTY SIX BY FORTY FIRST READING
WILL BE DEEMED READ.
UNDER CONSIDERATION ALL OF THE
DAILY FILE.
WE ARE A CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE WE ARE AT ASSEMBLY
THIRD READING FILE ITEM FOR
COLLEAGUES.
WE COULD HAVE YOUR ATTENTION WE
ARE AT FILE ITEM.
FOR MISTER SECRETARY PLEASE READ
ASSEMBLY BILL ONE FORTY NINE BY
ASSEMBLY MEMBER COOPER AND ACT
REALLY TO CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
AND CLAIM THEIR THROATS TAKE
EFFECT IMMEDIATELY.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN THE FLOOR
IS YOURS THANK YOU MADAM
PRESIDENT --
SENATORS TODAY RIGHT TO BRING
YOU AB ONE NINETY FOUR BY SOME
THEIR COOPER EIGHTY ONE NINETY
FOUR WILL ALLOW PATIENTS RESUMES
FILLING FILLING PRESCRIPTIONS
FOR CRITICALLY NEEDED MEDICATION
BY DELAYING THE IMPLEMENTATION.
OF A NEW REQUIREMENT ON SECURITY
PRESCRIPTION ALLOW THE
DEPARTMENT JUSTICE TIME TO
ENSURE THAT SERIAL NUMBERS ON
SECURITY PRESCRIPTION PADS ARE
VALID.
IT WILL ALSO ALLOW PRESCRIBERS
TIME TO COMPLY WITH THE NEW
REQUIREMENTS AND RELIEVE THE
ADMINISTRATIVE BURDEN OF
INDIVIDUALLY VERIFYING CERTAIN
PRESCRIPTIONS ON A CASE BY CASE
BASIS TO ENSURE.
PATIENTS CAN RECEIVE THEIR
PRESCRIPTIONS IN A TIMELY
FASHION THIS IS ABOUT CUTTING
THROUGH SOME ADMINISTRATIVE
ISSUES THAT HAVE COME UP.
AND BE SURE TO PATIENTS TO GET
THE MEDICATIONS THIS IS AN
URGENCY MEASURE THAT HAS HAD NO
NO VOTER RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU SENATOR PAN ANY DEBATE
OR DISCUSSION ON THIS ITEM
DEBATE OR DISCUSSION SENATOR
STONE.
THANK YOU --
BETTER PRESIDENT --
I STRONGLY SUPPORT AB ONE FORTY
NINE AND THAT THE LEGISLATION
HAD A EFFECTIVE DATE OF JANUARY
OF TWO THOUSAND NINETEEN PRIOR
TO PHYSICIANS BEING ABLE TO GET
THE SERIALIZED CHRISTIANS.
TO MONITOR CONTROL DRUG USE --
HERE IN THE STATE OF CALIFORNIA
SO IT -- PUT
PHARMACIST CERTAINLY IN A
QUANDARY BECAUSE WE WERE
RECEIVING IN THE NEW.
BLANKS AND YET WE HAVE
LEGITIMATE PRESCRIPTIONS FOR
LEGITIMATE CONTROLLED SUBSTANCES
THAT -- PUT
US IN HARM'S WAY THE STATE BOARD
OF PHARMACY FORTUNATELY.
PUT OFF THE AND THE ENFORCEMENT
UNTIL SUCH TIME THAT WE SAW
LEGISLATION LIKE RECEIVE HERE
TODAY THIS IS A COMMON SENSE
PIECE OF LEGISLATION TO LOBBY
MINISTRY OF TAX --
FAX OF ENFORCING THIS MISSUS AND
POSITIONS COMPLYING APPRECIATE
SENATOR PAMPERING A FORWARD.
THANK YOU SENATOR STONE ANY
FURTHER DEBATE OR DISCUSSION ON
THIS ITEM.
SEEING AND HEARING NONE CENTER
PAN.
WISH TO CLOSE UP ASPECT WE HAVE
TONIGHT BUT THANK YOU.
VERY GOOD CLOSE ALL RIGHT ALL
DEBATE HAVING SEIZED MISTER
SECRETARY PLEASE CALL THE ROLL.
ALLEN.
BY ARCHULETA.
BY ATKINS.
AYE BATES.
L..
BY FOR JUST [inaudible]
BY BRADFORD [inaudible]
I CABALLERO [inaudible]
I CHIANG [inaudible]
DODD [inaudible]
HI DORADO [inaudible]
I GALGIANI [inaudible]
BY GLAZER [inaudible]
GROWTH.
HERTZBERG.
AYE HILL AYE HUESO.
BY -- TADA
AYE JACKSON.
AYE JONES [inaudible]
BY LEYVA [inaudible]
BY MCGUIRE [inaudible]
BY MITCHELL [inaudible]
HI MONNING.
BY MORE LOCKED.
I'M REAL [inaudible]
BY NELSON.
I PAN.
AYE PORTANTINO [inaudible]
I ROTH [inaudible]
BY [inaudible]
RUBIO.
AYE SKINNER.
AYE STERN.
STONE.
BY NUMBER.
BY WHAT COUNTY.
AYE WIENER.
AYE WILK.
IRON BYE THE PLEASE CALL THE
ABSENT MEMBERS [inaudible]
BATES [inaudible]
CHIANG [inaudible]
HI [inaudible]
GLAZER [inaudible]
GROVE [inaudible]
I STERN.
ICE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO ON THE
URGENCY ICE THIRTY FIVE NO ZERO
ON THE MEASURE THE MEASURE
PASSES.
COLLEAGUES SAID IT COMPLETES OUR
DAILY FILE ITEMS AND IT IS TIME
NOW TO RETURN TO MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS THIS IS THE TIME.
TO ADDRESS THE JOURNEY IN MEMORY
MOTION.
A DO WE HAVE ANY CHURN IN MEMORY
SENATOR NIELSEN.
MADAM PRESIDENT LADIES AND
GENTLEMEN OF THE SENATE WHICH MY
HONOR TO ASK YOU TO ACKNOWLEDGE
AND THE GERMAN HONOR TODAY ONE
OF OUR OWN.
THE STEAMED FORMER MEMBERS.
SENATOR JIM ELLIS.
JIM ELLIS WAS BORN IN TULSA
OKLAHOMA AND MOVED TO COLORADO
IS A YOUNG MAN.
SIR TWENTY TWO YEARS IN THE
UNITED STATES AIRFORCE
[inaudible] FOR TERMS
[inaudible]
IN.
PORT TOURS OF DUTY IN VIETNAM ME
WAS OF PILOT.
HE WAS RECORDED FOR HIS SERVICE
THE BRONZE STAR TO DISTINGUISH
FLYING CROSSES STREET NAVY
COMBAT COMMENDATION MEDALS.
AND THE ERR MATT.
CERTAINLY A VERY ACCOMPLISHED
[inaudible]
AVIATOR.
THE UNITED STATES AIRFORCE.
THE SERVICE WELL.
CAME BACK HOME TO SAN DIEGO.
STARTED A CAR RENTAL BUSINESS.
STARTED WITH TWO VEHICLES.
HE ENDED UP WITH.
TWO HUNDRED AND LIKE MANY
[inaudible]
JIM ELLIS.
GOT PERTURBED WITH HOW.
GOVERNMENT WAS TREATING HIM OF
TAX THAT HAD BEEN IMPOSED.
ON CARS.
SO WE DECIDED TO DO SOMETHING
ABOUT.
AND HE WAS ELECTED TO THE CITY
COUNCIL [inaudible]
SAN DIEGO.
I BELIEVE HE SERVED THREE YEARS
THERE BEFORE HE THEN.
ASCENDED TO TO THE STATE
ASSEMBLY.
SERVED IN THE STATE ASSEMBLY FOR
ABOUT THREE YEARS AND THEN CAME
TO THE CALIFORNIA STATE SENATE.
I HAD THE PRIVILEGE OF SERVING
WITH JIM HERE.
HE WAS A MEMBER OF THE RULES
COMMITTEE.
OF THIS HOUSE. FOR SOME TIME.
HE WORKED IN MANY AREAS.
HE CARED A LOT ABOUT DISABLED
[inaudible]
YOU.
HE WORKED ON PROPERTY TAX
[inaudible]
REFORM.
AND HE PROCEEDED.
PROP THIRTEEN WITH HIS EFFORTS.
THE REFORM THAT ONEROUS PROPERTY
TAX BURDEN.
THAT WAS TAKING.
OUR ELDERLY OUT OF HOMES AND
MAKING IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
EVER SECURE HOME.
SO WE KIND OF PRE.
PROP.
THIRTEEN HE DID NOT.
CHOOSE TO ACCEPT IT AND RUN FOR
A THIRD TERM.
IN [inaudible]
EIGHTY EIGHT HE THEN.
CAME AND SERVED A TWO YEARS I
BELIEVE ON THE AGRICULTURAL
LABOR RELATIONS BOARD.
JIM ELLIS WAS ALWAYS DRIVEN BY
WHAT WAS RIGHT HE WAS A SOFT
SPOKEN MEMBER OF THE HOUSE.
NOT BULLARD GERMAN ARGUMENTATIVE
[inaudible]
BUT FORCEFUL [inaudible]
AND CONVICTED [inaudible]
ANY FOUGHT.
IN THE RIGHT MANNER.
CONSISTENT WITH A SENATORIAL
COURTESIES WE VALUE HERE.
AND SERVE WILL THE CONSTITUENTS
OF SAN DIEGO AS A MEMBER OF THIS
BODY [inaudible]
HE MARRIED.
THE FORMER EMPLOYEE OF HIS.
ON THEN BECAME A CALIFORNIA
STATE ASSEMBLYMEMBER CAROL
BENTLEY.
CAROL ALSO SERVES IN TIME THE
BOARD OF PRISON TERMS.
AFTER HER RETIREMENT.
FROM THE ASSEMBLY AND SHE AND
JIM ESTABLISH RESIDENTS IN SAN
DIEGO.
IN REGULATION BY STICKING AROUND
THE COMMUNITY.
THEY WERE INDEED.
QUITE A POWER COUPLE.
WE EXTEND OUR SYMPATHIES TO
CAROL.
AS SHE MISSES HER JAM.
AND WE WHICH THAT JIM WHO SERVED
US SO WELL HERE ON EARTH.
WILL SERVE THE LORD WELL AND
HAVE A NAY WE ADJOURN AND JIM
ELLIS'S MEMORY CENTERED JIM
ELLIS ONE OF OURS.
THANK YOU CENTER NIELSEN OF
COURSE TO HIS FAMILY AND TO ALL
THE SENATE FAMILY OUR
CONDOLENCES.
SENATOR BRADFORD THE FLOOR IS
YOURS THANK YOU MADAM PRESIDENT
TODAY I RISE DURING THE MEMORY
OF A GREAT AMERICAN.
BY THE NAME OF AND YOU AARON AND
JUNIOR.
MR AARON WAS A MILITARY VETERAN
A COMMUNITY LEADER FATHER FATHER
NEIGHBOR AND A MENTOR OF MINE.
BORN IN NEW ORLEANS LOUISIANA
DURING THE HEIGHT OF THE GREAT
DEPRESSION.
ANDREW AARON WHO WAS THE SECOND
OF FOUR SONS BORN TO HIS FATHER
AND YOU SENIOR AND HIS MOTHER
NAOMI FEELS ERIN AFFECTIONATELY
KNOWN AS JUNE BY HIS RELATIVES.
MISTER AARON ACQUIRED MANY
NICKNAMES DURING THE COURSE OF
HIS LIFE.
AS A YOUNG MAN.
MISTER AARON ANSWERED THE CALL
IN TO THREE AND A LISTED IN THE
MILITARY A SEGREGATED MILITARY
NONE THE LOS.
SERVING HIS FIRST TOUR OF DUTY
IN JAPAN HE CLIMBED MOUNT FUJI.
AND SECURED WITH ONE OF HIS MANY
FAMOUS NICK NAMES OF FUJI.
OUR WHILE SERVING HIS SECOND
TOUR HE FACE COMBAT DURING THE
KOREAN WAR CONFLICT AND WAS
INJURED IN THE LINE OF SERVICE
IN LATER BEING AWARDED THE
PURPLE HEART.
WHILE IN LISTED MR OUR AND OUR
INTERN.
TED DREWES BECAME FRIENDS WITH
HIS FELLOW NEW ORLEANS.
ON MR FALLON BUSH WHILE ON BREAK --
HE VISITED MR BUSH'S HOME AND
MATT.
ARE MISTER BUSH'S SISTER
GERALDINE ANY IMMEDIATELY FELL
IN LOVE WITH HER AND THEY
MARRIED IN NINETEEN FIFTY TWO
AND THEY'VE BEEN INSEPARABLE --
AS PARTNERS FOR SIXTY SIX YEARS
THEIR FAMILY GREW TO INCLUDE
THREE DAUGHTERS THREE
GRANDCHILDREN AND TWO GREAT
GRANDCHILDREN.
AFTER RELOCATING TO CALIFORNIA
MISTER ARE.
ANDREW AARON.
WORKED ARE BRIEFLY FOR THE
UNITED STATES POST OFFICE
ATTAINING GOALS LAWCENTER CITY
COLLEGE AND WEBER UNIVERSITY AND
WHILE CONTINUING HIS MILITARY
SERVICE IN THE U. --
UNITED STATES ARMY RESERVIST
WHAT ULTMATELY ALLOW HIM TO
RETIRE FROM THE ARMY WITH THE
RANK OF MAJOR FOLLOWING THIRTY
YEARS OF HONORABLE SERVICE.
HAVE AN UNDENIABLE COMMITMENT TO
A LIFE OF SERVICE [inaudible]
MR ARM.
PLEASE READ MISTER AARON.
OBTAIN A BACHELOR'S OF SCIENCE
DEGREE IN ACCOUNTING BEFORE
DEDICATING TWENTY FIVE YEARS
UNITED STATES CUSTOMS AGENT BUT
THAT WASN'T ENOUGH FOR HIM AFTER
RETIRED FROM THAT POSITION HE
STARTED SECOND CAREER AS A
UNITED STATES MARSHALS.
OFFICE.
HE WAS A CONSUMMATE VOLUNTEER IN
LA COUNTY AND THE CITY OF
GARDENA HE SHARED HIS LEADERSHIP
AND SAGE ADVICE WHAT'S UP
SEVERAL COMMUNITY ORGANIZATIONS.
SUCH AS THE GUARDIAN A SECOND
TIME AROUND SENIORS CLUB IN THE
NINTH AND TENTH CALVARY
ASSOCIATION OF THE BUFFALO
SOLDIERS ORGANIZATION THAT HE'D
LOVE TO THIS END OF HIS LIFE.
EMANA PROFOUND FAITH HE WAS A
PROUD MEMBER OF THE OLIVET
LUTHERAN CHURCH FOR FORTY YEARS
RE SAYING IN A CUT CHOIR AND
SERVED AS A DEACON.
MR AHRENS MEMORY AND LEGACY WIL
LIVE BY HIS WIFE AND THEIR
FAMILY MISTER AARON IS FOR LIFE
WILL FOREVER SHINE AND STAND AS
A BEACON OF HOPE. FOR ALL OF US
WHO STRONGLY BELIEVE THE PURPOSE
TO IMPROVE THE QUALITY OF LIFE
FOR CURRENT AND FUTURE
GENERATIONS MAY WE ARE GERMAN
AND MISTER ARENS MEMORY THANK
YOU.
THANKYOU SENATOR BRADFORD AND
IF YOU WOULD MAKE SURE THAT --
YOU BRING HIS NAME FORWARD SO
THAT WE CAN PROPERLY MEMORIALIZE
HIS MEMORY [inaudible]
SENATOR WIENER.
I FLOOR IS YOURS THANK YOU.
MADAM PRESIDENT OUR COLLEAGUES I
ODDS OF THE VERY VERY HEAVY
HEART THAT I ASK --
DIED THE SENATE TODAY DURING A
MEMORY -- OF
THE ELECTED PUBLIC OF SAN
FRANCISCO --
JEFF ADACHI WHO --
SUDDENLY --
AND VERY VERY TRAGICALLY PASSED
AWAY ON FRIDAY EVENING --
STUFF WAS A COMPLETE.
SHOCK -- TO
SAN FRANCISCO --
TO OUR POLITICAL WORLD TO OUR
COMMUNITY --
Là GREAT GREAT LEADER IN OUR
CITY AND I THINK WE'RE STILL ALL
OF US IN THE STATE OF SHOCK.
MISTER DARCY WAS IN THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE FOR THIRTY TWO
YEARS --
STARTING AS A YOUNG LAWYER --
AS A LINE DEPUTY WORKING HIS WAY
OUT. TO BE THE ODD I'D SHE FIVE
TRIAL ATTORNEY IN THE OFFICE AND
THEN ULTIMATELY IN TWO THOUSAND
AND TWO WAS ELECTED --
AS AND IT'S HELD THAT ROLE --
FOR SIXTEEN YEARS HAVING BEEN
ELECTED OFF OF FOUR TIMES.
JEFF WAS A REALLY A TEST OUR
UNIQUE OF PERSONA IN SAN
FRANCISCO --
FOR MANY REASONS --
HE WASN'T JUST YOUR TYPICAL
PUBLIC DEFENDER --
HE UNDERSTOOD THAT THE ROLE OF
PUBLIC DEFENDER WAS NOT.
ONLY TO GO IN THE CORE AND
DEFEND YOUR CLIENTS YES OF
COURSE THAT IS A CRITICALLY
IMPORTANT ROLE.
BUT HE VIEWED THE ROLE OF THE
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE MUCH
MORE BROADLY.
THE ADVOCATE FOR REFORM --
TO OUR CRIMINAL JUSTICE SYSTEM --
TO ADVOCATE FOR EVERYONE --
UNABLE TO ADVOCATE FOR
THEMSELVES --
WORKING IN THE COMMUNITY TO
SUPPORT AT RISK --
CHILDREN --
WORKING TO UNDOCUMENTED
IMMIGRANTS --
IN OUR COMMUNITY.
OUT WORKING TO SUPPORT PEOPLE
LIVING ON THE STREETS --
AGAIN NOT JUST.
THOSE IN THE CRIMINAL JUSTICE
SYSTEM BUT EVERYONE IN OUR
COMMUNITY --
AT RISK.
IN DOING THAT WORK --
JEFF -- WAS
NOT AFRAID TO RUFFLE FEATHERS --
YES OF COURSE HE WOULD FIGHT
WITH THE DISTRICT ATTORNEY'S
OFFICE OR WITH THE SHERIFF FOR
WITH THE POLICE --
AND HE FOUGHT HARD --
BUT AS SOMEONE WHO --
SPENT SIX YEARS AS A MEMBER OF
THE BUDGET COMMITTEE OF THE SAN
FRANCISCO BOARD OF SUPERVISORS.
I CAN TELL YOU HE WAS NOT SCARED
TO COME IN THE CITY HALL.
AND FIGHT WITH THE BOARD OF
SUPERVISORS AND THE MAYOR TO
MAKE SURE THAT HIS OFFICE.
WAS FUNDED AT LEVELS WHERE THEY
CAN PROVIDE THE SERVICE --
AND TO SERVE JUSTICE WHO WAS IN
NEED.
DODD JEFF'S LE HE TOOK WHAT WAS
ALREADY A REALLY REALLY GOOD
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE -
AND MADE --
I BELIEVE AMONG THE VERY BEST
PUBLIC DEFENDER'S OFFICE OFFICES
IN THE COUNTRY --
HE TOUCHED ELEVATED THIS OFFICE
ON SO MANY LEVELS.
AND IT IS HARD TO IMAGINE --
MOVING FORWARD I KNOW --
MY HEART GOES OUT TO HIS FAMILY
BUT LSO --
TO EVERYONE IN THE PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE --
WHO WILL HAVE TO MOVE ON I KNOW
THEY WILL --
BUT IT WILL BE HARD WITHOUT JOBS.
BY JEFF ALSO --
HE WAS A RENAISSANCE MAN OF
SORTS -- NOT
EVERYONE KNOWS HE WAS A
FILMMAKER FILMED SEVERAL SHORT
FILMS.
HE ALSO WROTE A VERY WELL
REGARDED --
BAR PREPARATION A COURSE FOR
PEOPLE TAKING THE BAR.
AND HE WOULD AT TIMES TUTOR
PEOPLE FOR FREE.
WHO WERE STRUGGLING WITH THE BAR
USES ONE OF THESE PEOPLE IN VERY
QUIET WAYS IN ADDITION TO VERY
PUBLIC WAYS?
BELIEVES IN HELPING PEOPLE.
HE GREW UP HERE IN SACRAMENTO
THE SON OF A CAR MECHANIC IN A
LABORATORY ASSISTANT.
AND HE IS SURVIVED BY HIS WIFE
WITH TO GO AND HIS DAUGHTER
LAUREN.
IN ADDITION TO THE HUNDREDS OF
PEOPLE ATTORNEYS AND STAFF --
IN THE SAN FRANCISCO PUBLIC
DEFENDER'S OFFICE WHO MISS HIM
DEARLY SO COLLEAGUES I ASKED
THAT WE ADJOURN AND THE MEMORY
OF OUR GREAT PUBLIC DEFENDER
JEFF ADACHI.
THANK YOU SENATOR WINNER AND
INDEED A LOSS FOR THE PEOPLE OF
SAN FRANCISCO USE QUITE A THE
REPRESENTATIVE OF HIS OF HIS
SERVICE TO THE PEOPLE.
ARE THERE ANY OTHER ADJOURNED IN
MEMORIES ANY OTHER MOTIONS AND
RESOLUTIONS [inaudible]
SEEING NONE.
SENATOR RECKONS THE DESK IS
CLEAR.
MADAM PRESIDENT THANK YOU SO
MUCH -- WE
WILL RECONVENE ON THURSDAY AT
NINE AM HAVE A GOOD AND
PRODUCTIVE WEEK [inaudible]
THANK YOU.
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL THREE THIRTY PM AT WHICH
TIME THE ADJOURNMENT MOTION WILL
BE MADE WE RECONVENE THURSDAY AT
NINE A. M.